THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE SERGEANT
AT ARMS WILL PREPARE THE CHAMBER
AND BRING IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA OUR QUE
HAN.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM BURNER HORVATH
[inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHAU
[inaudible]
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY DALY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY
[inaudible]
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LIMON ALONE.
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA.
MELENDEZ MULLIN MURATSUCHI
NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS RADIUS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH
[inaudible]
STONE.
TING VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WICKS WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND PATTY OSHA RENDITION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
HERE ARE A FEW FOOD NOTED FACTS
OF LIFE THAT CAN HELP US REGAIN
IN NINETEEN OUR ATTITUDE OF
GRATITUDE.
HOWEVER DIFFICULT LIFE MAY SEEM
FOR US AT TIMES.
WE ARE SO FORTUNATE TO LIVE HERE
AND NOW JUST AS WE ARE.
DAVID THIS CAR WROTE IN HIS BOOK
ENTITLED.
ONE IF WE HAVE FOOD IN THE
REFRIGERATOR CLOTHES ON OUR
BACKS.
A ROOF OVER OUR HEADS IN A PLACE
TO SLEEP.
WE HAVE MORE THAN 75% OF THE
WORLD'S POPULATION.
IF WE HAVE A LITTLE MONEY IN THE
BANK OR SPRIT SPARE CHANGE IN
THE DEUCE SOMEWHERE.
WE ARE AMONG THE TOP 8% OF THE
WORLD'S WEALTHY.
IF WE CAN DRINK FROM MY KITCHEN
TAP OR EVEN OUR GARDEN HOSE
WHENEVER WE WANT.
WE ARE MORE FORTUNATE THAN ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION PEOPLE IN THE
WORLD.
WHO HAVE NO ACCESS TO CLEAN
WATER?
IF WE ARE ABLE TO READ THEN WE
ARE MORE FOR LESS THAN TWO
BILLION PEOPLE IN THE WORLD WHO
CANNOT READ.
IF WE CAN ATTEND A CHURCH OR
TEMPLE OR POLITICAL RALLY.
WITHOUT FEAR OF HARASSMENT
ARREST TORTURE OR DEATH.
WE HAVE THE KIND OF FREEDOM
DENIED TWO THREE BILLION PEOPLE
ON THE FACE OF THE EARTH.
WHEN WE TAKE A MOMENT TO
CONSIDER OUR LIFE CIRCUMSTANCES?
HOWEVER DIFFICULT THE MAY BE AT
TIMES.
WE HAVE ALREADY BEEN LIVING A
LIFE FOR WHICH WE CAN BE TRULY
GRATEFUL.
NUMBER ONE THE NUMBER SEE WHAT
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND OUR STAFF WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS SHE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE.
READY BEGIN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE -- THANK YOU
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
MOVING TO READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY MAY TWENTY THIRD TWENTY
NINETEEN RECENTLY MET AT TEN AM
ON LOWER BACK OF OUR QUE HANNAH
ASSISTANT SPEAKER PRO TEM OF
THIS MISTER CALDERON MOVES IN
MISTER FLORES SECONDS THAT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE TO
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S ABSENCES ARE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NEWS ARIAN FOR
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MELENDEZ FOR
PERSONAL BUSINESS.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MISSION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER A. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY
THREE DOLLY AND SB SIX SEVENTY
FOUR MCGUIRE FROM THE H. G. O.
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE SB SIX EIGHTY
Y. KOWSKI TO THE AN ACTOR FIVE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
UBER IS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY.
TODAY I WANT TO WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER MEMBERS FROM
MOMS DEMAND ACTION.
THEY'RE HERE TO PROMOTE WHERE
ORANGE IN NATIONAL GUN VIOLENCE
AWARENESS DAY.
WHICH WILL BE JUNE SEVENTH.
WHERE ORANGE IS AN AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN DEDICATED TO HONORING
THE LIGHTS OF AMERICANS AFFECTED
BY GUN VIOLENCE?
IN ELEVATING THE VOICE OF EVERY
AMERICAN WHO DEMANDS AN END TO
GUN VIOLENCE.
THIS JUNE THERE WE HUNDREDS OF
EVENTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
INCLUDING FIFTY ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
FROM COMMUNITY SERVICE PROJECTS
TO MARGE'S PICNICS AND BLOCK
PARTIES.
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS WILL
PARTICIPATE IN WHERE ORANGE
EVENTS NATIONWIDE.
IS THEY STAND UNIFIED IN AN
EFFORT TO AND GUN VIOLENCE.
LANDMARKS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WILL GO ORANGE IN SUPPORT OF
NATIONAL GUN VIOLENCE AWARENESS
DAY INCLUDING SAN FRANCISCO'S
QUITE TOWER AND THE ICONIC
CAPITAL RECORDS BUILDING IN
GREEK THEATER IN LOS ANGELES.
GUN VIOLENCE RAVAGES MANY TOO
MANY FAMILIES AND NEIGHBORHOODS.
ESPECIALLY IN OUR CITIES IN
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
AS WELL AS OTHER MARGINALIZED
GROUPS.
INCLUDING THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY.
WE ARE DEDICATED IN THIS BODY TO
WORKING TOGETHER TO MAKE THIS
COUNTRY SAFER ALL AMERICANS.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
MONTH ME AND ACTION FOR GUN
SENSE AMERICA TO THE CHAMBERS
TODAY.
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE.
ASSEMBLY SECOND READING THE
CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE FORTY FOUR AND
SIX EIGHTY ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
ITEMS ON RECONSIDERATION WILL BE
CONTINUED.
MOVING TO THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE -- IN A FILE ITEM
FIVE ACR NINETY THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SOMETHING CURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY
RELATIVE TO FOSTER CARE MONTH.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO MR CURLEY MISTER
COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES GOOD MORNING.
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT ACR.
NINETY WHICH DESIGNATES LAST
MONTH MAY AS FOSTER CARE MONTH.
AND OF COURSE THE FACT I'M
PRESENTED THE DAYS JUST
REFLECTION UPON MY OWN FRAILTY.
HAVING MISSED TWO WEEKS OF WORK
WITH PNEUMONIA.
I'M A DAY LATE.
DAY LATE.
BUT I'M DELIGHTED TO BRING THIS
FORWARD.
FOSTER CARE IS SUCH A VITAL
FUNCTION.
YOU KNOW IT'S A CHARACTERISTIC
OF OF JUST OUR HUMANITY.
ALL OF US EVERY INDIVIDUAL.
THE WHATEVER CHALLENGES THEY MAY
FACE IN LIFE WHATEVER
CIRCUMSTANCES BE SET THEM.
ALL OF US DO BETTER IN MEETING
THOSE CHALLENGES.
IF WE HAVE RELATIONSHIPS PEOPLE
WHO ARE CLOSE TO PEOPLE WHERE WE
EXPERIENCE LOVE AN AFFIRMATION
SUPPORT [inaudible]
WITHOUT THAT.
EVERY OBSTACLE SEEMS
INSURMOUNTABLE.
WITH THAT.
WE FIND SOMEHOW THE RESERVES IN
THE FORTITUDE TO PERSEVERE AND
PREVAIL.
AND THAT IS WHAT LIFE IS ABOUT
BUT THAT IS WHAT GROWING UP IS
ABOUT FOSTER CARE MONTH.
IS THE TECHNOLOGY MEANT THAT
THERE ARE KIDS.
WHO DO NOT HAVE FAMILIES IN THE
HUESO MOST OF US DID GROWING UP?
AND YOU'RE IN FOR A PLACE WHERE
THEY HAVE LOVE AN AFFIRMATION
SUPPORT.
IN THIS WHAT THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM PROVIDES.
AND I WOULD BE REMISS ON THIS
DAY OF NOT A FOR ME THAT TWO OF
MY GRANDDAUGHTER GRANDCHILDREN.
LITTLE ANNA LITTLE BEEN CAME OUT
OF OUR OWN SECOND A COUNTY
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
AND IN OUR PART OF THE COOLEY
FAMILY.
OF CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE HAVE
BEEN REMOVED FROM THEIR FAMILIES
TO ABUSE OR NEGLECT.
THEY OFTEN SUFFER SYMPTOMS AKIN
TO POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER.
AND WHILE THE GOAL IS ALWAYS TO
REUNIFY THESE CHILDREN WITH
THEIR FAMILIES.
WE KNOW THAT CANNOT ALWAYS
HAPPEN [inaudible]
INSTEAD WE A OFFER LEVELS.
RELATIVE CARE GIVERS FOSTER
FAMILIES FROM ORANGE SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC HOMES.
TOMORROW.
I WILL GO TO A FUNERAL FOR A
WOMAN BETTY Là FEVER
[inaudible]
WHO?
LIVE DOT FOSTER PARENT TEEN TO
INFANTS.
AND I KNOW HER AND HER HUSBAND.
OVER MANY YEARS PROBABLY HAD
FIFTY OR SIXTY INFANTS. FOR WHOM
THEY PROVIDE OF TENDER LOVING
CARE -- IN A FOSTER NEED SETTING.
A WE RECOGNIZED MAY AS FOSTER
CARE MONTH TO BRING AWARENESS TO
THE ISSUE THE CHILDREN FACE.
WE KNOW THAT FOSTER YOUTH HAVE
LOWER EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT
EMPLOYMENT HOUSES STABILITY.
AND THESE PROGRAMS ARE ALL
DESIGNED TO HELP.
GIVE THEM THE WHERE WITH ALL TO
DO WITH LIFE.
OF IS FINE WE CAN FIGURE ARE
FORCED TO THE OLD SUPPORTERS
CITY.
THAT IS A PERENNIAL ISSUE IN OUR
STATE BUDGET FORTUNE GRATEFUL
FOR THE WORK OF OUR BUDGET
CHAIRS AND OTHERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO FIRST ROLE TO BE
OPEN TODAY FOR COAL AUTHORS ON
ACR.
NINETY AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY MISTER
CHOI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IN THE
MEMBERS OR SO I A A RISE IN
SUPPORT OF A C. R.. NINE THE TWO
DECLARED MONTH OF A MAY BE SO
FOSTER CARE MON.
AS A MEMBER OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE OF FOSTER CARE I STAND
TO RECOGNIZE.
THE US SIXTY ONE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED THIS SIXTY A CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN AND OFF.
YOU WITH IN FOSTER CARE.
WHO OR NIAZ SECA A STABLE SAFE
AND LOVING HOME?
IN ORANGE COUNTY -- THEIR RAW
NOR LAST AND TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
YOU WITH A PLEASED IN.
FOSTER CARE.
MY DISTRICT STAFF.
FOR OR SOLD SHARES ABOUT THE
TOOL FOSTER CHILDREN.
THIS IS SO AMAZING YOU WITH.
STRUGGLE TO A GRADUATE OF FROM --
HIGH SCORER AND THE MOST ARE
SUSCEPTIBLE TOOL HOMELESSNESS
AND IN COSTA INCARCERATION.
AFTER A AGING OUT OF THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM.
I BELIEVE WELL I CAN SAFELY SAY
THAT THE WE ALL MUST DO MORE TO
AID THAT THIS YOU WITH A IN
ACHIEVING THE BEST.
CHANCE SO FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO
LIVE FAR AND STABLE -- FUTURE.
COLLEAGUES I THINK THAT THIS IS
SET ENTIRELY APPROPRIATE. TO
DEDICATE THIS MONTH AND THE SHOW
ARE WAS SUPPORT TO THE FOSTER
FAMILIES WITH THE OUR HAWKS.
AND ENOUGH LAW. TO SHARE OUR
FOSTER YOU WITH THAT AND THE
CHILDREN.
I OFFERED YOU A TO A VOTE I ON
H. E. R. NINETY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHOI DISTRESS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
AS CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ACR NINETY
WHICH RECOGNIZES THE MONTH OF
MAY IS FOSTER CARE MONTH.
IT IS OUR DUTY IS LEGISLATORS TO
PROVIDE FOR THE MOST VULNERABLE
AND OFTEN THIS INCLUDES OUR
FOSTER YOU.
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
A VERY IMPORTANT STATISTIC THAT
WE CAME ACROSS IS THAT THE
AVERAGE AGE OF OUR FOSTER YOUTH.
THE AVERAGE AGE OF OUR FOSTER
YOUTH IS EIGHT YEARS OLD THEY'RE
IN THIRD GRADE.
AND THE TYPICAL TIME SPENT IN
THE SYSTEM IS APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY MONTHS.
THIS MAKES THEIR TIME SPENT IN
THE SYSTEM POTENTIALLY THE
SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT PERIOD.
OF THEIR YOUNG LIVES.
MEMBERS WE MUST DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO HELP LIFT OUR FOSTER
YOUTH AND ALL OF THOSE TO
SUPPORT THEM.
BOTH AS INDIVIDUALS OR IN THE
PUBLIC OR PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT WORK TO ENSURE THEIR SAFETY
AND THAT THEIR NEEDS ARE MET I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS REYES SEEING AND
HEARING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION MYSTICALLY COOLEY MY
CLOSE.
I THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR
COMMENTS AND I ASKED THE ROLE TO
BE OPEN FOR COAUTHORS.
MISTER COOLEY IS ASKING AT THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR QATAR'S
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS VOTE IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
ACR.
NINETY ALL MEMBERS.
WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE CO AUTHORS?
THIS VOTE IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING
CO AUTHORS ON ACR NINETY WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION ALL IN
FAVOR SAY YE.
OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MOVING TO FILE ITEMS. SIX BILL
PASS TEMPORARILY FILE ITEM SEVEN
THROUGH TWELVE WE PASSED A
RETAINED.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM THIRTEEN ACR
NINETY FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETY FIVE BY SOME NEW MEMBER
CHOI IN OTHERS RELATIVE TO
SECURE LOW DAY.
MR CHOI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
DONNA.
MEMBERS SAW.
THIS TIME.
I STAND TO INTRODUCE ACR NINETY
FIVE DECLARING JUNE SIXTH.
S. IS SECURE YOU'LL MOLD DAILY
IN CALIFORNIA.
ACR NINETY FIVE IT IS A
SIGNIFICANT TO ASA BECAUSE SO
EVERY DAY -- PEOPLE ARE INJURED
OR KILLED.
DUE TO ON SECURED THAT THE
BREEZE SO AND CALIFORNIA.
EACH OF US I'M SURE HAS BEEN NOT
HAS SEEN THE ALSO PICK UP TRUCKS
OR DRIVING DOWN THE HALLWAY WITH
THE THINGS OF BLOWING.
OUT OF THE BED AND THE
DISRUPTING TRAFFIC INJURING AND
THE KILLING PEOPLE.
A STUDY CONDUCTED THE BY TRIPLE
A FOUNDATION FOR TRAFFIC SAFETY
SHOWS THAT THE NEARLY ONE
HUNDRED DEATH.
AND THE TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND THE
MORTAL VEHICLES ACCIDENTS ARE
ARE IN RESULT.
OF THE UNSECURED MOLD IT'S DAY
IN CALIFORNIA.
WHILE THE LAW ALL CURRENTLY
PROVIDES SO FINE SO AND CHARGES
SO FOR DRIVING UP WITH THE ON
SEE GOOD THE ROLE SO IT IS SO
OFTEN THE VICTIMS.
OF HIS ACTIONS NOT THE RECEIVER
NOR JUSTICE.
VICTIMS ARE USUALLY LEFT WITH A
SHOULDER.
THE DAMAGES CAUSED OF THEMSELVES
SO DUE TO THE NATURE THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL SO WHO FAILED TO
SECURE THE OLD SAW -- LONG GONE.
ACR NINETY FIVE US SIMPLY IT
RECOGNIZES.
JUNE SIXTH.
AS A SECURE LOW DAY TO BRING
AWARENESS TO CALIFORNIANS.
THE IMPORTANCE OF A SECURING.
ONE IS LORD.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHOI WOULD YOU
LIKE THE FIRST ROLE TO BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS.
YES PLEASE OKAY SEEING AND
HEARING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE FOR AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS VOTE IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
ACR.
NINETY FIVE THIS VOTE IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
TALLY THE VOTE THERE ARE FIFTY
NINE CO AUTHORS ON ACR NINETY
FIVE WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN H. R. FORTY
TO THE CLERK WILL READ HOUSE
RESOLUTION FORTY TO BUY
SOMETHING MEMBER KANSEN CHU AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO IMMIGRANT
HERITAGE MONTH.
MR CHIU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS RESOLUTION THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER.
AS SOON RECENT IMMER GRAHAM WHO
CAME TO THE UNITED STATES AS A
GRADUATE STUDENT.
WITH THE OF BOUQUETS ON MY HAND
AND BIG DREAMS TO MY HEART.
I AM VERY VERY HONORED AND BE
ABLE TO PRESENT THIS -- HR FORTY
TWO AND AND THIS -- HOUSE -- I
JUST WANTED TO SHARE SOME OF MY
OF EXPERIENCE AS A IMMIGRANT.
AND I LIKE TO SHARE TO OFF THE
MOST ASKED QUESTION TO ME.
AFTER I GOT ELECTED TO THIS
HOUSE A CITY COUNCIL WHICH
REPRESENT THE HEART OF SILICON
VALLEY.
THE FIRST QUESTION IS THAT
PEOPLE WILL ASK ME HOW CAN WE
DUPLICATE.
SILICON VALLEY IN OTHER PLACES
IN THE NATION OR OUTSIDE OF THE
UNITED STATE.
AND MY ANSWER ALWAYS THAT BEHAVE.
THE SILICON VALLEY YOU KNOW GOOD
FOR THE WIDER BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY IS A VERY VERY
DIVERS -- AREA AND IS INCLUSIVE
IN THOSE IS MAKE WHAT THE
SILICON VALLEY.
SILICON VALLEY TODAY.
AND THE SECOND QUESTION THAT WAS
ALL I'M MOSTLY ASK BY PEOPLE
WITH THE IMMIGRANTS WHO CAME TO
THIS COUNTRY BUT FOR ME ONE
GENERATION TO GENERATION OR MANY
GENERATIONS BEFORE ME.
THEY ALWAYS QUESTION A BALL
MIGHT DILIGENCE TO TO THE UNITED
STATES.
OF TO THAT QUESTION I USED TO
ALWAYS ANSWER WAS A STRAIGHT
HOME.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO MISTER.
TO I I ALWAYS ANSWER THE
QUESTION WHAT THE WHAT WHEN
PEOPLE QUESTION ME OF ALL MY
ILLUSIONS.
IS THAT I LOVE THIS COUNTRY MORE
THAN YOU DO.
BECAUSE I HAVE THE CHOICE I
CHOOSE TO BE THERE AMERICAN
CITIZEN.
SO YOU KNOW WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT MAKING AMERICA GREAT I
THINK IS MOST IMPORTANT THAT WE
EMBRACE AND THE TWO AMERICAN
VALUE.
YOU KNOW WE NEED TO HELP HOW WAS
THE NEW IMMIGRANTS YOU KNOW HELP
THEM THE TO THE TO STE ESTABLISH
A ROUTINE IN THE UNITED STATES.
BECAUSE ONCE THEY DO THAT YOU'LL
DAY CONTRIBUTE A LOT TO OUR
ECONOMY AND SO ON I HAVE SOME
STATICS THE STATUS OF THE CASE
HERE.
THAT IMMIGRANT BRING LIFE AND
ENERGY TO OUR STATE AND IN THIS
ECONOMY.
THE WORLD'S FIFTH LARGEST
IMMIGRATION IMMIGRANTS ACCOUNT
FOR SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTEEN
BILLION.
OF CALIFORNIA GOOD DON'T --
DOMESTIC PRODUCT.
AND ALSO PAYS SEVEN POINT SEVEN
BILLION IN THE STATE LOCAL AND
SALES TAX.
SO I WILL.
I WILL LOOK -- LIKE YOU -- TO
ASK FOR THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN
VOCAL AUTHOR.
AND US FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
H. R. FORTY TWO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
SEEING AND HEARING NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
PLAYERS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
MR CHU IS ASKING FOR CO AUTHORS
ON HR.
FORTY TWO THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE THERE ARE SIXTY
THREE CO AUTHORS ON HR FORTY TWO
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION
ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SIX A. C. R.
SIXTY FOR THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY RELATIVE TO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION MR MCCARTY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS
MEASURE IS PART OF OUR PACKAGE
TO LOOK AT THE COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS PROCESS IN.
FRANKLY REGARD TO THE OPERATION
VARSITY BLUES WHERE THE SCANDALS
WITH COLLEGE ADMISSIONS AND IT'S
RELATED TO THE SAT AND ACT EXAM.
THIS WON'T ELIMINATE IT THIS
WON'T COME UP WITH ANY
CONCLUSION IT WILL JUST ASK THE
UC BOARD OF REGENTS IN THIS CSU.
TRUSTEES TO STUDY THE USEFULNESS
EFFECTIVENESS AND THE NEED WE
KNOW ACROSS THE COUNTRY THERE
ARE THOUSAND UNIVERSITIES
ALREADY PHASED OUT THE SAT AND
ACT.
UTILIZING BOTH YOUR GPA AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY YOUR CLASS RANK.
WE KNOW THAT.
WITH THESE RECENT REPORTS WITH
THE INDICTMENTS BACK EAST THEIR
INDIVIDUALS OF COURSE YOU WERE
CHEATING FAKING DISABILITIES FOR
THEIR STUDENTS.
ARE HAVING PROCTOR'S.
CORRECT THE ANSWERS HAVING IN
THE PAYING INDIVIDUALS TAKE THE
TEST FOR THEM WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THERE ARE.
LEGAL WAYS TO SOMETIMES
MANIPULATE THESE SAT EXAMS.
CERTAIN COMMUNITY SORT
INDIVIDUAL CERTAIN FAMILIES HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO PAY FOR
CERTAINLY THE VERY EXPENSIVE
CALLS TEST PREP.
AND THAT DOESN'T ALWAYS PROPERLY
REFLECT THE TRUE -- ACADEMIC.
POSSIBILITIES FOR STUDENTS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA SO THIS WILL
JUST GIVE US A AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THESE EXAMS
WHETHER OR NOT THERE WERE THE
FOR UNIVERSITIES GOING FORWARD
AND AGAIN THERE ARE THOUSAND
UNIVERSITIES OUR COUNTRY THAT
ARE TAKING THE STEPS.
ASK THE RIVAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY.
DO YOU WANT THE FIRST ROLES WE
OPEN FOR CARTER'S MISS MCCARTY
YES SEEING AND HEARING NO OTHER
MEMBERS TO GET RECOGNITION THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE FIRST ROLE
FOR COOPER.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS VOTE IS VOTERS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE THERE ARE FIFTY
FOUR CO AUTHORS ON A C. R. SIXTY
FOUR WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS
RESOLUTION ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE THE AYES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MOVING TO THIRD THE SENATE THIRD
READING FILE ITEMS FIFTEEN
THROUGH EIGHTEEN WILL BE PASSED
IN RETAINS.
MOVING TO A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FILE ITEMS TWENTY ONE
THREE TWENTY FOUR IS ANY MEMBER
WISH TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING ON THE CLERK
WILL READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR HOUSE RESOLUTION THIRTY
FOUR BY FAMILY MEMBER MCCARTY
RELATIVE TO LOVING DAY.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESERT VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE I SEVENTY TWO NO.
ZERO SAN CALENDARS ADOPTED THE
CLERK WILL READ THE REMAINING
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO
FIFTY TWO I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO
AND SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTY I SEVENTY TWO NO.
ZERO MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS.
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS.
FRIDAY UNE SEVENTH THERE IS NO
FLOOR SESSION AND NO CHECK IN
SESSION MONDAY JUNE TENTH.
FLOOR SESSION IS AT ONE PM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED INTERCHANGE.
ALL MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
JUNE TENTH AT ONE PM.
FORM CALLS LIFTED